[Musik]
grundsatzurteil im abgas skandal
volkswagen muss schadenersatz zahlen an
zehntausende diesel kunden milliarden
für die lufthansa airline und
bundesregierung einigen sich auf ein
gewaltiges rettungspaket und heftiger
streit um die virus regeln lockerungs
pläne in thüringen und sachsen stoßen
auf neue breite kritik
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem montag ein stoppschild für vw vom
bundesgerichtshof das urteil zeige dass
ein großer konzern nicht über dem gesetz
steht so jubelt der anwalt des klägers
fast fünf jahre nach auffliegen des
diesel skandals haben die höchsten
zivilrichter erstmals darüber
entschieden ihr urteil
vw habe gezielt getäuscht die käufer
haben anspruch auf schadenersatz heißt
kläger können ihr auto zurückgeben und
den kaufpreis zurückverlangen müssen
sich aber die gefahrenen kilometer
anrechnen lassen
das urteil ist richtungsweisend für
60.000 weitere klagen nicht betroffen
davon sind all jene kläger die dem von
den verbraucherzentralen ausgehandelten
vergleich mit vw zugestimmt haben david
franke dreieinhalb jahre kämpft sich
herbert aus dem landkreis bad kreuznach
durch alle instanzen einem vergleich von
vw lehnte er ab er will ein urteil für
alle fordert für seinen vw sharan eine
entschädigung schließlich wurde an
seinem lisa getrickst der
bundesgerichtshof gibt gilbert heute
überwiegend kriegt der schaden liegt
schon im kauf des manipulierten
fahrzeuges vw hat vorsätzlich und
sittenwidrig gehandelt die folge der
kläger kann danach vor der beklagten
erstattung das für sein fahrzeug
gezahlten kaufpreises verlangen er muss
sich aber den gebrauch des fahrzeuges
liegende nutzungs vorteil anrechnen
lassen und vw das fahrzeug zur verfügung
stellen sprich die gefahrenen kilometer
von gilbert hier 50.000 werden
angerechnet vom kaufpreis abgezogen
er bekommt demnach anstatt den kaufpreis
von 31.500 euro jetzt 25.600 euro
dennoch ist er zufrieden ein toller tag
so ein tolles urteil ist ein urteil mit
dem ich auch gerechnet habe was nicht
mehr mir hilft denn das urteil gegen vw
gibt rechtssicherheit für rund 60.000
weitere anhängige verfahren an dem land
und oberlandesgerichten der konzern will
nun reagieren
volkswagen wird jetzt dieses urteil
nicht nur im einzelfall sondern
allgemein umsetzen und auf die
liga zu gehen und versuchen die
verfahren im größtenteils
schnellstmöglich zu beenden
ein längst überfälliges grundsatzurteil
dass herbert gebert heute vor dem
bundesgerichtshof erstritten hat felix
zimmermann ist bei mir aus unserer
rechts redaktion felix lange vor diesem
urteil haben sich ja schon 240.000 vw
kunden mit dem konzern geeinigt im
rahmen der muster feststellungsklage auf
entschädigung zwischen 1300 und 6000
euro sind das jetzt die dummen nein das
kann man so pauschal nicht sagen also
dass heute hier der kläger 25.000 euro
etwa zugesprochen bekommen hat die zum
ersten daran dass er den wagen
zurückgeben muss das müssen die kläger
im musterprozess nicht tun und zum
zweiten daran dass er sehr wenige
kilometer gefahren das ist 50.000 den
letzten jahren hatte den wagen wohl
wissen dass sie kilometer möglicherweise
angerechnet werden in der garage stehen
lassen
als faustformel lässt sich sagen wie
viel mit seinem dieser unterwegs war
der dürfte durch den vergleich im
musterprozess sogar besser abgeschnitten
haben kann denn jetzt überhaupt noch
jemand klagen wer damals ein
manipuliertes auto gekauft hat also
zwischen das sagt die ganz herrschende
meinung ist das ganze verliert wenn
jetzt also das bgh urteil zum signal
leben will zu klagen ist wohl zu spät
dran
und das betrifft ganz ganz viele leute
in deutschland muss sich vorstellen es
gibt ja 2,4 millionen fahrzeuge die vom
diesel skandal betroffen waren
vw-konzern mäßig und von nur 25 prozent
der betroffenen haben tatsächlich
geklagt heißt im umkehrschluss bei 75
prozent der betroffenen muss vw jetzt
gar keine entschädigung zahlen
also eine große menge die sich der
konzern hier erspart
anders übrigens in den usa dort gibt es
ein effektives sammelklageverfahren und
dort wurden sämtliche betroffenen
entschädigt ganz unabhängig davon ob sie
geklagt haben so etwas gibt es aber
leider in deutschland nicht ja danke
schön felix zimmermann führt diese
einschätzung und informationen
es war ein zähes ringen jetzt haben sich
bundesregierung und lufthansa auf ein
gewaltiges rettungspaket geeinigt 9
milliarden euro staatshilfe soll die in
bonner zeiten angeschlagene
fluggesellschaft bekommen
neben krediten durch die staatsbank kfw
wird sich der bund auch mit 20 prozent
direkt an der lufthansa beteiligen
zustimmen müssen noch die gremien des
konzerns und diätenkommission und bibel
offenbar harte auflagen durchsetzen
klaus brodbeck nach langem stillstand
geht dann alles auf einmal ganz schnell
am späten nachmittag in berlin
wettlauf der beteiligten minister um
eine gute nachricht das engagement das
wir hier vorbereiten dass 1 auf zeit
wenn das unternehmen wieder flott ist
dann wird der staat seine anteile
veräußern und das hoffe ich jedenfalls
nicht nur als bundesminister der
finanzen auch mit einem kleinen gewinn
es geht um über 100.000 arbeitsplätze es
geht darum dass deutschlands führende
position auf den weltmärkten in der
zivilen luftfahrt gewahrt bleibt die
lufthansa soll mit insgesamt neun
milliarden euro stabilisiert werden drei
milliarden als kredit durch die
staatliche kreditanstalt für
wiederaufbau kfw und private banken
weitere sechs milliarden vom wirtschafts
stabilisierungsfonds der größte teil als
stille einlage der staat erhält aber
auch 20 prozent der aktien
dieser anteil kann um weitere mindestens
fünf prozent aufgestockt werden etwa um
eine übernahme zu verhindern
den beschäftigten bringt das
voraussichtlich etwas wo
arbeitnehmervertreter aber bleiben
skeptisch
allerdings ist den rettungspaket keine
einzige politische leitlinie drin
das ist viel symbolpolitik aufsichtsräte
keine boni aber eine wirklichen schutz
von 138.000 mitarbeiter den gibt es da
nicht vorbehalte auch bei der opposition
der staat ist nicht der bessere
unternehmer
in der tat ist es deshalb geboten auch
ein ausstieg festzulegen damit eben dass
keine unendliche geschichte wird die
bundesregierung stellt mit 9
milliarden steuergeld ein und da muss
man sich ein stärkeres mitspracherecht
organisieren als die bundesregierung wie
es jetzt getan hat aktionäre und
europäische kommission müssen der
einigung zustimmen und wieder mehr
geflogen wird noch lange nicht es bleibt
also schwierig wirtschaftsminister
altmaier schlägt auch weitere hilfen für
den mittelstand vor im umfang von
mindestens 25 milliarden euro
firmen mit bis zu 249 mitarbeitern
sollen demnach von juni bis dezember
monatlich bis zu 50.000 euro bekommen
können
ziel sei es in der korona krise die
existenz von kleinen und mittleren
unternehmen zu sichern
die pläne sind noch nicht mit dem
finanzministerium abgesprochen in sachen
corona hat die bundeskanzlerin heute
eine klare ansage gemacht sie will dass
hygieneregeln wie abstand und masken
pflicht bleiben
eine reaktion auf den vorstoß des
thüringer ministerpräsidenten ramelow
der möchte nämlich ab sechsten juni
allgemeine corona regel aufheben und
stattdessen auf eigenverantwortung
setzen und auf lokale lösungen sein
argument in der hälfte der thüringischen
landkreise gäbe es seit drei wochen
keine neuinfektionen aus erfurt dann
jeder sonntag schluss mit dem
krisenmodus thüringens ministerpräsident
will einen strategiewechsel und sorgt
damit für diskussionen
weniger allgemeingültige vorschriften
mehr lokale lösungen denn die
infektionsrate sei niedrig wenn man aber
in ganz thüringen nicht einmal 250
infizierte menschen mehr hat dann muss
man einfach zur kenntnis nehmen dass man
dann nicht noch die polizei losschickt
und in der fußgängerzone kontrollieren
lässt
ob möglicherweise zwei familien die da
miteinander laufen nun wirklich in
jeweils einem haushalt leben oder nicht
das ist das was ich denke was wir jetzt
beenden müssen
mundschutz nur noch in bus und bahn
abstandsregeln nach bedarf mehr gebote
statt verbote
doch was heißt das nun konkret im alltag
der ministerpräsident bleibt dazu waage
mancher thüringen
irritiert aber dann diese
unterschiedlichen umgehens waisen machen
halt auch wieder neue verunsicherungen
und ich glaube aus dem dilemma kommt man
da draußen
ich bin ein bisschen ängstlich auch in
berlin große skepsis abstand mundschutz
und hygiene sollen pflicht bleiben auch
nach dem fünften juni darauf bestehe die
kanzlerin so der regierungssprecher
zurückkehren an arbeitsplätze in schulen
in restaurants in sportvereine aber eben
auch gleichzeitig die grundregeln weiter
achten das ist die haltung der
bundesregierung die grünen regieren in
thüringen mit auch von ihnen scharfe
kritik an rahmenlos vorschlag der
vorstoß von bodo ramelow war ein bodo
ramelow vorstoß er es nicht abgestimmt
gewesen mit dem grünen koalitionspartner
und ich hoffe dass ich die debatte auch
so entwickelt das diesen vorstoß nicht
nachgegeben wird in sachsen allerdings
soll thüringen zum vorbild werden auch
hier könnten verbote wegfallen wenn
veranstalter oder pflegedienstleister
dafür hygiene konzepte vorweisen
in erfurt will morgen das kabinett über
den vorschlag diskutieren mit dem streit
um die geplanten lockerungen beschäftigt
sich auch ein zdf spezial gleich nach
und wenn man aufs ganze land schaut
sinkt die zahl der täglichen
neuinfektionen weiter
so kommen im durchschnitt der
vergangenen sieben tage täglich 570
ansteckungen dazu insgesamt wurden mehr
als 180.000 infizierte registriert davon
gelten mehr als 161.000 als genesen 8300
menschen sind in verbindung mit cupid 19
gestorben
wieder hat es in einem schlachtbetrieb
eine corona massen infektion gegeben
diesmal nicht in deutschland sondern in
den niederlanden in dem schlachthof in
grundlos an der deutschen grenze sind
147 beschäftigte positiv getestet worden
davon leben 79 auf deutscher seite der
betrieb wurde geschlossen
immer wieder gibt es in schlachthöfen
viele krone infektionen offenbar weil
der arbeits abstand zu gering ist und
leiharbeiter in gruppen unterkünften
leben
die korona pandemie wirft auch ein
schlaglicht auf das umstrittene geschäft
mit leihmüttern in deutschland ist dass
eltern verbot
in ihren kinderwunsch zu erfüllen in der
ukraine nicht
dort wurden mehr als 100 sei klinge
geboren und bisher nicht abgeholt es
sind babys die ukrainerinnen gegen geld
für ausländische paare ausgetragen haben
die eltern können ihre neugeborenen aber
wegen der geschlossenen grenzen nicht zu
sich holen
in hotels angemietet von den
geburtskliniken werden die kinder
versorgt christian sind gerade erst
geboren und schon gestrandet
krankenschwestern versorgen die
leihmutter babys in diesem hotel in kiew
wegen der korona reisebeschränkungen
können die eltern aus dem ausland ihren
neugeborenen nicht abholen
für ein kind zahlen paare bis zu 65.000
euro
wir bekommen ein mal die woche fotos und
videos von manu sie haben einen video
anrufe gemacht als er einen monat alt
wurde
aber es ist sehr hart
mit diesem marketing video wollte eine
ukrainische leihmutter agentur werbung
machen und druck ausüben auf die
behörden wegen der gestrandeten bebens
entstanden ist eine diskussion über das
umstrittene weltweite geschäft der
ukraine und der leihmutterschaft
wir schätzen dass mehr als 100 kinder
von leihmüttern in der ukraine betroffen
sind kinder von bürgern verschiedener
länge aus europa asien viele aus china
die eltern der kinder kommen aus mehr
als 40 ländern
irina will unerkannt bleiben sie ist 32
hat schon ein kind als leihmutter zur
welt gebracht bekam dafür 8000 euro ihr
mann weiß davon die familie nicht und
sie wird es noch mal tun auch für ihr
eigenes kind das an epilepsie erkrankt
ist sie braucht das geld
ich habe einen traum ein eigenes kind
wächst auf und ich will dass es eine
eigene wohnung eine zukunft hat aber das
wichtigste ist dass es auf die beine
kommt und gesund wird die journalistin
daniela pokert bei ihren recherchen mit
verschiedenen leihmüttern gesprochen
sie weiß unter welchem druck die frauen
oft stehen uns erzählt haben dass
manchmal ihre eigene familienmitglieder
gar nicht wissen dass sie leute sind
nähe berührung emotionale bindung all
das muss noch warten denn noch sind die
ukrainischen grenzen geschlossen
brasilien ist nach den usa das land mit
den weltweit meisten corona fällen jetzt
verhängen die usa einen einreise stoppt
er gilt ab freitag für alle ausländer
die in den vergangenen zwei wochen in
brasilien waren
unterdessen ist ein politisch exklusives
video aufgetaucht es stellt den
rechtsradikalen präsidenten ball zu nach
bloss aus rio christoph rath
es ist eine kampfansage an alle seine
kritiker ohne maske ganz nah ran ball zu
nahrung hat noch immer kein konzept zur
eindämmung des corona virus vorgelegt
stattdessen feiert er am sonntag wieder
seine anhänger an sich gegen die
schutzmaßnahmen aufzulehnen
wie ernst er es meint zeigt nun die
veröffentlichung des videos einer
kabinettssitzung aus dem april die
brasilien erschüttert ich will dass sich
alle bewaffnen bewaffnete werden sich
niemals versklaven lassen der oberste
gerichtshof hat das video freigegeben
boll szenario flucht und beschimpft
seine gegner das parlament sei
überflüssig die obersten richter
gehörten eingesperrt sagen seine
minister und der umweltminister
schockiert mit seinem plan gerade jetzt
die abholzung des regenwaldes
voranzutreiben
jetzt wo wir gerade ruhe haben weil die
presse sich nur mit kurven 19
beschäftigt sollten wir den moment nutzt
warum die vereinfachung der ganzen
regeln und normen voranzubringen
politisch besonders brisantes goldzone
aros aussage dass er in die
sicherheitsbehörden eingreifen will um
seine familie vorermittlungen zu
schützen
ich werde nicht zulassen dass sie meine
familie so wörtlich [ __ ]
dies könnte sofern bewiesen sogar sein
amt gefährden denn es wäre
amtsmissbrauch kaum eine rolle dagegen
spielen die opfer und die bekämpfung der
pandemie
viele menschen sind entsetzt diese
sitzung hatte er etwas vom treffen einer
straßengang an der ecke als vom treffen
zwischen ministern und dem präsidenten
eines landes das ein ernstes problem hat
brasilien befindet sich in einer
schweren politischen krise
während sich das virus weiter ausbreitet
zurück nach deutschland und zu einem
verbrechen das in seiner brutalität
selbst erfahrene ermittler schockiert
jahrelang hat ein logopäde ihm
anvertraute jungen missbraucht zwei bis
sechsjährige geistig und körperlich
behinderte jungs in der kita heute
sprachen die richter in würzburg ein
klares urteil
petra neubauer berichtet dieser mann
sollte eigentlich therapieren und hat
doch so viel schaden angerichtet
elf jahre und vier monate haft wegen
schweren sexuellen missbrauchs das
urteil nimmt oliver h ohne erkennbare
regung auf das gericht hat ausgeführt
dass der angeklagte einige pluspunkte
verschenkt habe indem er keine echte
reue und keine echte anteilnahme im
laufenden verfahren gezeigt habe
in dieser würzburger kita kümmerte sich
oliver h als logopäde vorwiegend um
behinderte kinder auch in einer anderen
betreuungsstätte und in seiner praxis
sollte er ihnen helfen sich besser zu
verständigen
doch jahrelang in mehr als 60 fällen
verging er sich hier an sieben ihm
anvertrauten jungen zwischen zwei und
sechs jahre alt von den taten fertigte
er aufnahmen an verbreitete sie im so
genannten darknet einem besonders
abgeschotteten teil des internets
nun darf oliver hahr lebenslang keine
männlichen jugendlichen mir therapieren
die betroffenen familien hätten sich ein
strengeres urteil eine
sicherungsverwahrung gewünscht aber wir
dürfen uns durch so etwas nicht in die
knie zwingen lassen wir haben dann keine
energie mehr für das um was es wirklich
geht und das sei nicht oliver h sondern
die geschädigten kinder zu ihrem schutz
hatte dieser prozesse auf größtenteils
unter ausschluss der öffentlichkeit
stattgefunden
ein neuer service für bahnreisende in
corona zeiten die bahn app soll nun auch
anzeigen wenn fernzüge zu mehr als 50
prozent ausgelastet sind
dann können fahrgäste auf weniger
ausgelastete verbindungen ausweichen
gleichzeitig wird die zahl der
reservierungen begrenzt
außerdem will die bahn vom
pfingstwochenende an wieder mehr züge
einsetzen
endlich wieder touristen in mecklenburg
vorpommern dem beliebtesten inlands
reiseziel der deutschen dürfen hotels
pensionen und ferienwohnungen ab heute
wieder gäste aus der ganzen republik
begrüßen allerdings mit einem
reduzierten angebot und verschafften
hygieneregeln eine stadtfeld und banken
seebach ziel erreicht heike und wolfgang
ertel aus thüringen sind gerade
angekommen in ihrem korb am strand von
warnemünde vier meter abstand nach
hinten zwei meter fünfzig zur seite
matthias treichel und seine strandkörbe
stehen bereit für die saison 10
quadratmeter zur verfügung also ein
besseres quarantäne zentrum kann es
nicht geben die leute sind geschützt im
strandkorb der touristische betrieb
fährt wieder hoch in mecklenburg
vorpommern mehr gebucht hat das kommen
tagestouristen müssen allerdings vorerst
draußen bleiben
die hotels sind vorbereitet abstand
hygiene rücksicht und verzicht nur 60
prozent der zimmer dürfen belegt werden
wenn sie diese regularien einhalten
menschen nicht sehr sehr schwierig sind
für den gast dann können sie nach wie
vor einen wunderschönen wohl auch wir
verbringen die rasse ist trotzdem
forderten die zeit der leeren strand
körper ist vorbei die tourismusbranche
im land hat bisher 400 millionen euro
verlust eingefahren
für uns bedeutet das im wahrsten sinne
des wortes rückenwind also wirklich in
den dunklen zeiten die wir jetzt
durchgemacht haben und durch machen
viele viele wochen geschlossen wie der
gäste aus ganz deutschland begrüßen zu
dürfen bei uns ist als tourismusland
sehr sehr wichtig die saison startet in
mecklenburg vorpommern spät langsam und
vorsichtig immerhin sie startet
buch steffen sei dank das wetter wird
jetzt von tag zu tag wärmer und sonniger
wo es morgen noch ein wenig regnet sagt
katja hornuf claus kleber begrüßt sie
viertel 14 im heute-journal danke für
ihr interesse alles gute ihnen und bis
morgen wenn sie mögen auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
genau meine damen und herren das hoch
liegt westlich von uns und deswegen
zogen über deutschland heute viele
wolken aber nicht nur wolken sondern
auch regenschauer
da sehen sie an den kleinen blauen
punkten die zogen von mecklenburg
vorpommern nach sachsen aber auch von
thüringen weiter richtung bayern und
auch in baden württemberg waren einzelne
schauer unterwegs in der schau luft
blieb ist recht kühl heute nachmittag
dann lagen dann die höchsttemperatur nur
so zwischen 13 und 17 grad
mit sonne im westen ging es dagegen auf
21 22 grad auf heute nacht sinken die
temperaturen am rhein im rhein main
gebiet oder auch an den küsten von nord-
und ostsee auf 9 grad richtig kalt wird
es dagegen im nordhessischen bergland
mit 3 grad
auch heute nacht gibt es noch letzte
regenschauer besonders in sachsen und in
bayern morgen beschränken sich diese
regenschauer aber doch meist auf das
berchtesgadener land sondern wolken
wechseln sich ab und das bei einem
böigen wind aus nördlichen bis
nordwestlichen richtungen und so bleibt
es morgen kühle temperaturen von 16 grad
auf rügen aber immerhin 24 grad im
breisgau
in den nächsten tagen geht es sonnig und
doch recht warm weiter und auf den
dringend erforderlichen regen warten wir
meist vergeblich schön hat noch